recalibrar las relaciones es el lema
elegido por el gobierno de joe biden
para justificar el controvertido viaje
del presidente estadounidense a arabia
saudita en campaña by the navy ha
prometido tratar al reyno de paria pero
el contexto global con altos precios del
petróleo y la inflación disparada
llevaron a un cambio de discurso en las
reuniones con el rey salman y el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman
baiden según sus asesores no evitará
abordar el respeto a los derechos
humanos en medio de las críticas por el
asesinato en 2018 del periodista ya
maneja shocks y del que la cia acusa a
la corona saudita maiden además va a
participar de una cumbre con los líderes
de arabia saudita emiratos árabes unidos
bahrein kuwait qatar omán egipto
jordania e iraq así se espera que el
presidente estadounidense discuta sobre
seguridad energética y pida un aumento
de la producción de petróleo para
reducir los precios aunque la casa
blanca no espera que eso ocurra en los
inmediatos maitén también pretende
destacar la presencia de eeuu en medio
oriente para no dejar un vacío que
pudieran llenar naciones como china
rusia o irán en esta estrategia
incluiría israel para eeuu y ya logró un
primer paso luego de que rían abriera en
espacio aéreo a vuelos desde y hacia
israel otro posible acuerdo sería
permitir viajes directos entre israel y
arabia saudita para peregrinos
musulmanes mientras que el gobierno
israelí aprobó un plan para que dos
islas del mar rojo pasen de egipto a
control saudita bajo garantías de
mantener la libre navegación con eso se
logró se espera irse bardem de medio
oriente aunque sabiendo que una
normalización total de relaciones entre
israel y arabia saudita es un proceso
más complejo y que no se dará en el
corto plazo